the united states has recognized wand
why though as the legitimate president
of venezuela launching an international
campaign to oust the narco dictator
nicolas maduro more than 50 governments
have back to idle as Venezuela's
constitutional president why though has
called him a duro to cede power to a
transitional government and he has
attempted to win the Venezuelan military
to his cause
thus far Maduro and his criminal cronies
have resisted US sanctions and
diplomatic pressure they have amassed
fortunes from stolen oil revenue in
cocaine trafficking so they have simply
too much to lose
US diplomats have called on the military
leaders to oust Maduro as well however
an April rebellion plotted by why those
team failed after producing only a
handful of defectors wide oh have now
agreed to negotiations but Maduro may
only offer elections where the regime
holds all the cars many predict that
Maduro will never step aside for quite
all unless he is forced out by
Venezuelan Patriots fighting for their
country do you think the current US
strategy will produce a change in
Venezuela let us know in our poll and
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI